[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette suite
lectorat vis de vous retrouver pour 25
minutes d'actualité locale
au sommaire de ce vendredi 7 février les
résultats d'un projet européen présenté
dans les yvelines à versailles satory
ses hôtes au pilote un projet concernant
les véhicules autonomes du tourisme nous
avons suivi de l'événement depuis la
désignation de paris pour accueillir les
jeux olympiques de 2024
une semaine est organisée chaque année
pour mettre le sport à l'honneur auprès
de la jeunesse
un représentant de crêpes ile-de-france
sera avec nous au plateau pour ma part
avec un chantier plan lycée à saint cyr
l'école
le lancement de la concertation pour la
fusion des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine est une application pour
améliorer le diagnostic des patients
nous reviendrons sur ce qui a marqué le
département cette semaine le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner et son
secrétaire d'état laurent nunez se sont
rendus ce vendredi matin à vélizy
villacoublay pour la cérémonie de prise
de fonction de frédéric veaux le nouveau
directeur général de la police nationale
le ministre a rappelé l'importance de
cette fonction est la priorité faite à
la lutte contre le terrorisme
61 attentats ont été déjoués sur le sol
français depuis 2013
il lui a également demandé une action
pour contrer le fléau des suicides dans
la police
frédéric veaux je vous demande d'être à
l'avant poste du combat pour la sécurité
des français à l'avant poste aux côtés
de la gendarmerie nationale de la
préfecture de police et des services de
renseignement au combat
collectivement pour les français notre
première priorité est et reste la lutte
contre le terrorisme et la
radicalisation vous y alliez créant
votre temps une division de lutte contre
le terrorisme islamiste au sein de la
sous direction antiterroriste
je vous demande de continuer le combat
et de ne jamais baisser la garde dans le
cadre du chef de file à de la dg ainsi
la porte parole du gouvernement si bête
n'diaye et est aujourd'hui aussi dans
les yvelines afin d'échanger avec les
différents acteurs de terrain engagé
dans l'intégration républicaine elle a
participé à une cérémonie de
naturalisation à la préfecture des
yvelines comme vous le voyez en images
avant de s'entretenir avec le préfet
jean-jacques brot
dernière escale à plaisir pour une
visite du quartier du valais bout ainsi
que la de la maison des familles
la mosaïque c'était l'évènement final
d'auto pilote un projet européen mené
par des industriels des centres de
recherche et des acteurs publics pour
développer le véhicule autonome
les résultats ont été présentés à
versailles-satory et notamment une
expérimentation développé par vd comme
reportage de nicolas d'andré des
véhicules autonomes et connectée c'est
le principe de ces voitures
d'expérimentation développé par vd comme
en collaboration avec versailles grand
parc
l'idée est de créer des véhicules
autonomes de tourisme avec un système de
convoi connecter aux infrastructures
urbaines
un des aspects intéressants de cette
démonstration à des expérimentations
qu'on a pu mener c'est justement s'est
inspiré de communication avec les fleurs
c'est à dire que à la proche d'un feu le
feu y connecter le véhicule de tête va
demander le passage au vert du fun devra
demander une autorisation pour pouvoir
passer
cette expérimentation s'inscrit dans le
projet auto pilot des recherches menées
depuis 2010 est sur six sites de
développement avec 45 partenaires issus
de 15 pays européens des acteurs privés
et publics orientés vers un objectif
améliorer le véhicule autonome grâce à
l'internet des objets du monde de la
recherche du monde dans l'industrie du
monde des services du monde des
télécommunications et tous ces
industriels se sont réunis sous la
houlette de l'union européenne pour
démontrer qu'on peut faire progresser
des technologies véhicule autonome grâce
aux objets connectés et à la
connectivité ce dont on est convaincu
c'est que l'avenir réside dans la
connectivité dans la communication entre
tous ceux qui circulent sur la route
au total six projets ont été présentés à
versailles-satory l'union européenne
investit près de 20 millions d'euros
dans ses travaux de recherche et
développement
[Musique]
michel coll vous êtes avec nos bons
jours bonjour alors vous êtes le
directeur de communication du creps ile
de france le centre de ressources
d'expertisé de performances sportives en
charge de soutenir notamment les
sportifs de haut niveau avec vous nous
allons parler de la préparation aux jeux
olympiques 2000 24 dans les yvelines
auprès de la jeunesse notamment avec
cette semaine annuelle dédiée mais à
d'avant actualité oblige je voulais
revenir avec vous sur ce qui percute le
monde sportif en ce moment les violences
sexuelles dans les yvelines aussi avec
cet entraîneur d'un club de foot à
magnanville mise en examen est soupçonné
de viols et agressions sexuelles sur
mineure alors même qu'il avait été
condamné pour des faits correctionnels
d'agression sexuelle en 2008
est ce que ces violences ont quelque
chose vous nous créez avait conscience
est ce qu'il ya des démarches qui vont
êtres qui sont prises alors tout à fait
bonjour marie lehn merci de m'accueillir
oui le creps ile de france est vraiment
moteur sur ces problématiques de
violences sexuelles et d'encadrement de
bizutage de pratiques qui vont un petit
peu au-delà de ce qui est respectable et
concernant les violences sexuelles on
était plutôt lanceur d'alert puisque des
mois d'avril avec la ministre des sports
auxerre marseille nous on avait lancé
une une conférence une conférence avec
un rugbyman qui avait été violée et qui
en fait qui a fait la tournée ensuite de
l'ensemble des établissements de
français et on avait sensibilité de
sensibiliser pardon nos 250 jeunes
pauliste ainsi que tous les encadrants
du creps ile de france et je vous en
parlerai un peu plus tard
voilà c'est assez problématique là aux
signaux qui permettent de détecter la
personne qui subissent des pressions et
qui en difficulté et au mois d'août fin
août avec la rentrée de la nouvelle
génération qui rend au creps ile de
france
eh bien on a fait une journée complète
d'animations d'écouté on a eu nous aussi
quelques quelques cas qui ont émergé qui
ont permis à un moment donné aux jeunes
de libérer la parole parce que je crois
que c'était ça qui était le plus
important c'est d'arriver à libérer la
parole pour faire en sorte que les
jeunes filles ou les jeunes garçons
parce que c'est valable pour les deux
sexes puisse puisse parler évoquée et
puis surtout sensibiliser et trouver les
moyens d'agir et de répondre maintenant
je vais revenir à cette semaine
olympique et paralympique organisé
auprès de la jeunesse jeunesse quel est
l'objectif de cet événement alors cet
objectif c'est surtout de faire partager
l'esprit olympique
l'esprit de solidarité et la découverte
de tout un tas de pratique sportive pour
pour tous les jeunes alors on a on a eu
la chance d'accueillir des jeunes
primaires comme des jeunes lycéens
d'ailleurs du département 78 nous avons
eu plus 107 108 jeunes qui sont venus 57
lycéens en gros et des écoles primaires
aussi je donnerai les noms tout à
l'heure et qui ont participé et les
sensibiliser non seulement à la pratique
de différentes activités donc on a eu du
badminton du tennis de table du tennis
fauteuil du basket du hand du volley
ball à 6 du basket fauteuil
on a eu du handball aussi et puis
surtout en point d'orgue de cette
semaine on a rassemblé pour la première
fois au creps ile de france et c'était
leur premier rassemblement national
aussi l'équipe de breakdance qui va
représenter la france aux jeux
olympiques de paris 2024 avec la
jeunesse faire monter en puissance tout
le monde faire en sorte que tout le
monde à un moment donné s'imprègne de
cette logique des jeux s'imprègne de
l'aspect culturel aussi autour des jeux
parce qu'il faut savoir que on a mis en
place une exposition aussi sur 1924 pour
qu on a 100 ans des jeux olympiques et
que au jeu de paris 1924 l'aspect
culturel l'aspect littérature était
aussi récompensé comme des jeux
olympiques de la littérature comme des
jeux olympiques d art et donc
nous avons retracé toute cette
exposition 1924 avec un film avec tout
ça et nous l'objectif c'était aussi de
faire d'ouvrir les jeunes ce regard sur
sur les arrêts sur la culture
donc il y avait un temps culturel très
fort avec des quizz avec du sport santé
et avec des expositions qui leur
permettait de comprendre quelles étaient
les l'ancêtre des jeux open contre
puisque les premiers jeux à paris on
lyon il ya cinq ans en 1924
concrètement si l'on passe hélas déjà
souvenu toute la semaine toute lassitude
600 jeunes plus 1200 jeunes qui ont été
accompagnés donc par des sportifs de
haut niveau qui ont été accompagnés par
des stagiaires de notre formation
professionnelle puisse conforme à peu
près 1500 personnes aux métiers du sport
parents qui les ont cadré sur les avis
de ces deux là forment sur les activités
de santé et bien entendu avec des
spécialistes de l'activité qui sont bas
l'entraîneur de basket l'entraîneur de
basket fauteuil
les entraîneurs de breakdance qui les
ont accompagnés pour leur faire
découvrir sentir vivre leur discipline à
travers tout ce qui pouvait leur
transmettre et n'avoir d'autre des
actions dans cette lignée dans les
yvelines alors dans les yvelines
en tout cas le chrétien offense des
propositions en ile-de-france oui on est
la seule la seule la seule organisation
qui avait regroupé autant de jeunes sur
la semaine avec toute la communication
qu'on a fait et nous sommes rentrés tout
à l'heure il ya eu l'engagement de
l'ensemble des partenaires de cet
événement qui fait que tous les ans
jusqu'aux jeux de paris 2024 y aura la
réédition de cette semaine on lui donne
encore plus d'ampleur plus d'impact une
ouverture beaucoup plus grande vous
restez avec nous on va parler de jeunes
yvelinois que nous retrouverons sûrement
à ces jeux olympiques
tous deux étaient présents dans le 7-8
sport ce lundi le premier à 21 ans et
s'illustre comme cavalier il a commencé
en montante et poney dès l'âge de 3 ans
il s'entraîne à la boissière école et il
a été retenu par la française des jeux
pour intégrer la fdj factory un
dispositif qui accompagne les jeunes
sportifs de haut niveau dans leur
carrière et pour les amener jusqu'au
chose olympiques de 2024
le second à 19 ans pour lui c'est le
rugby il joue au racing 92 a été
sélectionné en équipe de france moins de
20 ans pour le tournoi des six nations
il est originaire duminil saint denis où
il débute avant d'aller au sky rugby et
aujourd'hui à maurepas on écoute donc
victor levêque et fabien geeks une
énorme fierté de faire partie de cette
team c'est la chance de pouvoir être au
contact de 27 athlètes ont été choisis
objectifs parer 2024 c'est aussi un
soutien financier qui nous permet
d'apporter d'apprendre des dockers
sportive plus sereinement
et puis c'est aussi un accompagnement
pour le formation professionnelle et
notre conversion du plaisir ma grande
fierté forcément après j'espère que le
début et donc du coup c'est toujours ça
donne encore plus envie de travailler
quand on est avec le groupe c'est
vraiment la bonne humeur qui règne et où
donc forcément envie d en vidéo a
expliqué alors au creps aussi vous
accompagner de jeunes sportifs les jeux
olympiques qui approchent j'imagine que
c'est une chance particulière pour eux
c'est une échéance particulièrement il
faut savoir que pour être aux jeux
olympiques comme ces deux jeunes that
est sans doute qu'ils ont été détectés
par leurs fédérations respectives la
fédération d'équitation et la fédération
française de rugby il faut globalement
dix ans et dix mille heures de travail
pour former un athlète qui va aux jeux
olympiques donc quand on a aujourd'hui
l'antichambre des équipes de france qui
sont à 2024 sont passés à un moment
donné par le creps ile de france mais on
a 17 disciplines olympiques
on accueille aussi les jeunes rugbymen
du racing à midi on avait un athlète un
ambassadeur du sport rugbyman qui était
présent aussi pour accompagner nos
jeunes athlètes et en gros donc on est
là pour être des générateurs de la
performance de ses athlètes leur donner
les meilleures conditions d'entraînement
scolaires aussi parce qu'ils ont un
projet à la fois sportive bien entendu
mais aussi un projet scolaire tous les
établissements scolaires qui sont autour
du creps jouent le jeu aménagement du
temps scolaire qui permettent à un
moment donné d'arriver à cette a7 a7s
excellence la voilà on parlait peut-être
tout à l'heure de sports en fauteuil la
seine saint denis accueille un projet
unique en europe le prisme pour pôle de
référence inclusif sportif métropolitain
c'est notre passage en dehors des
yvelines avec nos confrères via quand
paris la seine-saint-denis et paris 2024
côte à côte pour préparer l'héritage des
futurs jeux olympiques et paralympiques
le projet prisme a été officiellement
lancée un équipement pensé pour
accueillir tous les sportifs qu'ils
soient valides ou en situation de
handicap
une première en france et en europe
il n'existe pas de des équipements
sportifs dont la conception dès
l'origine à une vocation de permettre la
pratique universelle du sport à la fois
par des personnes valides mais aussi les
personnes en situation de handicap et de
tous types de handicaps et donc
c'est le pays tout entier grâce à prisme
qui fera un pas très fort un pas en
avant très ambitieux en matière
d'inclusion conçu à la fois pour les
pratiques de loisirs et le haut niveau
le complexe de 8200 m² pour accueillir
jusqu'à 2000 usagers
un projet de longue date qui a connu un
coup d'accélérateur avec la perspective
de 1024 où on a dit ma là on a le projet
des jeux il faut qu'on se mette autour
de la table et donc avec le mouvement
sportif avec les collectivités locales
et avec l'état on a réussi à trouver le
bon compromis le bon calibrage pour que
ce projet puisse vraiment à voir le jour
et de cocher les cases de ça sert le
territoire ça sert le sport et notamment
le sport paralympique parce
qu'aujourd'hui on manque d'équipements
sportifs complètement accessible avec
cette accessibilité universelle livrés
fin 2023 prisme sera situé à bobigny
coût total de l'opération 44 millions
d'euros lors des projets plus inclusif
dans au creps nous fait attention à ces
chalands ont fait beaucoup attention à
ça nous on à améliorer nos conditions
d'hébergement avec la construction
notamment de 2,6 espace d'accueil pour
personnes en fauteuil ou à mobilité
réduite et il nous arrive souvent
maintenant d'accueillir des personnes y
compris dans nos pôles espoirs on avait
une escrimeuse fauteuil on a eu du
tennis de tables fauteuils d'ailleurs ça
faisait partie de notre semaine
olympique aussi et on a du basket
fauteuil et je pense qu'on a travaillé
aussi avec l'ile-de-france pour essayer
d'avoir peut-être la délégation de rugby
ben du rugby fauteuil qui va peut-être
venir se préparer chez nous dans un très
prochain
voilà donc on a les équipements on a
rendu l'accessibilité on a mis en place
des ascenseurs dans nos différents
équipements et puis aujourd'hui les
gymnases sont accessibles sont rendus
accessibles comme nos salles de
spectacles sont rendus accessibles aux
personnes atteintes de handicap petit
point aussi c'est qu'on est ouvert aussi
aux handicaps mental et pas simplement
que physique puisque pour la préparation
des jeux de rio sous l'égide et en
partenariat avec la fédération française
du sport adapté
nous avions un athlète qui a été
qualifié pour la part pour les
politiques finale du 100 m are you on
arrive à la fin de cet entretien qu'elle
souhaite au creps pour les jo 2020 4 il
reste quatre ans et bien d'être vraiment
répertorié comme
espace d'excellence un espace de partage
et on a déjà pas mal de sollicitations
pour être base arrière des jeux
olympiques et on espère que l'ensemble
des départements du 92 mais aussi du 78
parce que je sais qu'on on sait que vous
êtes très actif au 78 par rapport à
cette pratique la couverture là on est
au milieu de dix sites olympiques
elie débat c'est bien entendu d'avoir
d'accorder le plus d'ouverture possible
et faire en sorte que le maximum de
jeunes de régions de france et des
départements limitrophes au creps
puissent pratiquer merci michel cohen
est venu sur notre plateau je le
rappelle est directeur de la
communication au creps ile de france
quant à nous on passe au reste de
l'actualité de la semaine merci madame
[Musique]
la visite jeudi de geneviève
darrieussecq au lycée militaire de saint
cyr l'école la secrétaire d'état auprès
de la ministre des armées est venu faire
un point d'étape du chantier lancé dans
le cadre du plan lycée les détails avec
aurélie rose point d'honneur à le faire
correctement première pierre pour ce
bâtiment qui offrira dès la rentrée
prochaine 180 places d'hébergement aux
élèves du lycée militaire de saint-cyr
coût de ces travaux est 7 millions
d'euros ils sont entièrement financés
par le plan lycée lancé par la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
des armées
nous avons besoin de conserver ses
infrastructures en bon état nous avons
pérennisé celis et pérenniser
l'enseignement qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur de ces lycées et même
augmenter les filières possibles et donc
nous avions besoin de travailler sur les
infrastructures dont certaines étaient
sont très vieillissante et nécessite
vraiment des améliorations ce bâtiment
modulaire de 2000 m² et la première
infrastructure nouvelle qui voit le jour
dans le cadre du plan lycée évolutif il
accueillera dans un second temps des
salles de cours donc on a en charge ses
travaux et par la suite d'autres travaux
qui en découlent dont notamment la
rénovation d'un bâtiment complet de
chambre et
les sanitaires de tous les internats
dans le bâtiment ancien qui date de
l'après guerre la france compte sur son
territoire si l'établissement de la
défense
plus de 110 millions d'euros vont ainsi
être consacrés jusqu'en 2025 à
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et de vie des élèves et des enseignants
l'école militaire de saint-cyr qui est
une nouvelle fois touché par un cas de
harcèlement sexuel sa direction a
déclenché une enquête interne et saisi
la gendarmerie l'armée de terre indique
dans un communiqué que des jeunes femmes
élèves ont rendu compte à leurs
référents mixité d'une situation de
harcèlement sexuel de la part d'un élève
masculin l'auteur présumé était éloigné
de l'établissement dès le 3 février jour
où les faits ont été dénoncés jeudi
journée nationale contre le projet de
loi sur les retraites à laquelle ont
participé les retraités dans les
yvelines et ont interpellé les 260
maires du département avec un courrier
ils sont notamment contre la retraite
par points et souhaite qu aucune pension
de soit inférieur au smic
quatorze maires ont répondu 9
soutiennent leurs revendications les
retraités se sont retrouvés devant la
mairie de versailles
on les écoute au micro de man varaldo et
jacques brun une retraite qui soit de
toute façon n'ont pas à 64 ans mais si
possible même un retour à 60 ans je
pense que le système par points est
profondément injuste
nous participons à la vie mais commune
donc les retraités ne font pas de des
privilégiés
nous sommes une partie de la population
et nous avons nos revendications notre
pouvoir d'achat
notre nos conditions de vie et une fille
pour se soigner et aussi son très actif
dans le mouvement contre la réforme des
retraites les avocats du barreau de
versailles depuis un mois ils
multiplient les actions parfois
originales le premier ministre edouard
philippe a reçu des représentants de la
profession cette semaine mais ces
annonces ne sont pas jugées
convaincantes et même incompréhensible
le barreau de versailles avait à voter
jeter la reconduction de la grève
jusqu'à lundi mandine blondin avocate du
barreau étaient en plateau du 7-8
journal ont fait un triste constat qui
est quand on s'oppose à un véritable mur
de la part du gouvernement
ah donc nous notre profession est
divisée au sein de barreaux qui sont
ensuite représenté au niveau national
parce qu'on appelle le cnb le conseil
national des barreaux qui depuis quatre
semaines a eu des formes de rencontres
avec d'abord notre ministre de la
justice madame b loubet et l'a récemment
depuis une semaine avec le premier
ministre edouard philippe est en réalité
on
ils se rencontrent ils échangent mais
absolument rien qui en ressort depuis
cinq semaines on a exactement les mêmes
propositions à coups de communiqués de
presse respectifs qu'ils disent
en réalité à chaque fois la même chose
donc pour ce qui est de la négociation
est en fait on n'a même plus de
négociations pour ce qui est des changes
avec le gouvernement c'est impossible
manifestement on doit s'y résoudre
maintenant nous au sein de nos deux
barreaux on envisage désormais de parler
plus avec nos députés ou des sénateurs
qui seront en fait l'étape d'après pour
espérer voilà avoir un échange avec des
personnes qui pourront influencer cette
réforme pas mardi les yvelines et les
hauts de seine ont voté leur budget
commun les deux collectivités réunies en
établissement public interdépartemental
l'ont entérinée pour l'année 2020 les
yvelines participeront à hauteur de 6
millions d'euros dans les crédits de
fonctionnement de l'entité parmi les
principales dépenses de le pays 14,3
millions d'euros pour l'entretien et
l'exploitation du réseau routier
départemental
plus d'un million d'euros en faveur de
l'archéologie préventive et encore 117
1000 euros sur le volet adoption
l'établissement a été créé pour rappel
en février 2007 volonté des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine d'aller vers une
fusion
une fusion qui est justement soumise à
concertation en ligne depuis jeudi pour
les trois millions d'habitants des deux
départements
le but n'est pas de demander s'ils sont
pour ou contre la fusion med informés
des enjeux et de leur permettre de
s'exprimer autour de six thèmes
développement économique emploi
innovation mobilité environnement et
cadre de vie solidarité et ruralité
culture et patrimoine et enfin la scène
le tout sur le site internet dédié qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran
votre téléphone pourrait bien vous aider
à sauver des vies
c'est en tout cas l'objectif d'urgence
times une start up basée à montigny le
bretonneux créée par trois personnes en
collaboration avec le salut 78 manon par
aldo a rencontré son dirigeant tout part
de son expérience personnelle suite un
accident de moto anthony tableau a frôlé
la part
l'isie à vie suite à un mauvais
diagnostic quand les pompiers sont
arrivés ils se sont rendus compte qu'ils
avaient mal évalué le niveau de gravité
même les pompiers ont fait au moins ses
rangs ils m'ont dit bon écoute on
n'avait pas compris que c'était un
résultat aussi un truc grave c'était le
conducteur de la voiture qui avait
renversé qui avait appelé qui avait fait
la meilleure description possible et les
pompiers m'ont dit si on avait su on
aurait envoyé une équipe médicalisée
donc là on peut rien faire pour toi
juste servait dans mon travail à
l'hôpital
si les pompes il y avait pu me voir
avant de venir je n'aurais pas frôlé
cette paralysie avis anthony table you a
eu le déclic ray urgente time pour
améliorer le diagnostic le but localiser
les victimes en quelques secondes et
permettre au samu d'activer la caméra
des particuliers et mettre fin aux
appels abusifs
depuis trois ans son équipe a co
développé la solution avec le samu 78
allemand tant que ça mais je veux dire
ok je vois qu'il votre caméra pour à ce
qui se passe donc comment comment ça va
se faire je vais vous envoyer un lien
par sms donc vous coupez pas les niveaux
mais tu es en haut parleurs devrait se
mettre vous cliquez sur le lien et je
vais voir ce que vous voyez tout
l'intérêt du fait qu'ils aient pas coupé
la ligne c'est que si jamais la vidéo ne
marche pas pour une raison quelconque
ce qui paraît il n'y a pas de bande
passante n'ya pas d'internet on n'a pas
coupé le son le futur trentenaire et son
équipe ont gagné le prix smart paris
2024 urgente time sera utilisée pour les
jeux olympiques de 2024
ça permettra aussi aux étrangers est
rentrée mais plus décontracté ou plus
sera en disant qu'est si jamais un grand
moyen problème où je vois quelque chose
je sais que je pourrai montrer jure on
mettra aussi un traducteur en direct la
ministre de la santé agnès buzyn bien de
décidé de subventionner les appels vidéo
dans les samu à hauteur de 15 millions
d'euros entre 2020 et 2022 urgent times
est actuellement testé par le samu de
nantes autre start up en plein
développement implanté à montigny le
bretonneux exode games qui édite des
jeux de société créée en 2010 est cette
société connaît une forte croissance
grâce au développement notamment de son
jeu jurassic world en collaboration avec
universal les détails de cette réussite
avec nicolas d'entrée c'est la nouveauté
et le succès 2019 d'exode games le jeu
jurassic world 2 développé par cette
start up créée en 2017 est installé à
montigny le bretonneux
taux ne spécialisée dans l'édition de
jeux de société elle s'est associée à
universal pour créer ce wargame vous
allez créer votre faction développer
votre votre deck de cartes pour
constituer votre armée et faire un
scénario de que ce soit juste faire un
objectif ou alors affronter humains et
dinosaures ou incarner un dinosaure ce
qui est assez rare grâce à jurassic
world exode games a multiplié par trois
son chiffre d'affaires un demi million
d'euros récoltés avec les ventes
les équipes sont passées de 3 à 6
collaborateurs avec notamment l'arrivée
en avril 2019 de marion graphistes
designers ça peut être de la position de
textures ça peut être de la créa
complète en imaginant un visuel de
cartes ça peut être la mise en place
d'éléments
par exemple pour une boîte de jeu ou ce
genre de choses c'est assez varié en
fait n'est par exemple aller chercher de
la texture d'herbe dame brûler des
arbres de la pierre et tout assembler
ces éléments pour créer un environnement
on va dire logique et en même temps
assez esthétique exode games a lancé
aussi exode conception pour les
prototypes et des figurines 3d et exode
studio pour de futurs projets on a
quelques pistes pour développer si
certains jeux en jeux vidéo voir en film
d'animation
donc on essaie de toucher à tout ce qui
est vraiment le métier de l'intervenant
qui tourne autour du jeu en général ou
de l'animation et on espère que d'ici
cinq ans oui on aura développeurs un
studio de jeux vidéo
objectif pour x games dans les
prochaines années a réalisé 10 à 15 % de
croissance par an le festival pulsations
pensé par anima sera bel et bien
organisés à l'est de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
la convention a été signée lundi matin
l'association doit maintenant réfléchir
au point technique et financier avant de
recevoir ses festivaliers en septembre
2020 un nouveau rendez vous pour les
saint quentinois et pour l'y de loisirs
qui diversifie ainsi ses activités
les vacances scolaires commencent ce
vendredi pour occuper vos enfants un
rendez-vous danse à la commanderie à
elancourt
c'est les vacances c'est le nom de cette
semaine d'ateliers de découverte et de
création pour les enfants de 8 à 10 ans
un stage de danse de quatre jours avec
un professionnel mélanie pau qui a reçu
une représentante dans le 7-8 loi liste
loisirs les enfants vont traverser la
danse contemporaine mais de manière
ludique et joyeuse
ils vont expérimenter le plaisir la
création chorégraphique collectif qui
vont rester ensemble vraiment du lundi
au vendredi soir et voilà ils vont
improviser créé ensemble ce week-end
n'oubliait pas les premiers débats de
ces élections municipales en direct sur
notre antenne retour de l'actualité
locale dès lundi avec le 7-8 journal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]